doesn't something feel awful about all
this doctor rosa didn't mean to sneak up on
why would someone do this to live, I have to be afraid. Well, happy halloween!
someone is coming
more powerful than myself we have to get out of here
I warned you not to interfere you didn't
bring us here
no I discovered what it transpired on
earth to that you intervened to save
Laurel Lance I redirected you what the
hell happened back there a herald of
what is to come an entire world erased
from existence where's my mother
where's where's Tommy where's where's
Rene where's Dinah they are no more
did you hurt John and laurel they're alive nearby and now you know that if we fail to stop
the coming crisis what you witnessed
will occur on Infinite Earths across the
expanse of time
you should have told me what was going
to happen on earth 2
John was there he could have been
the destruction of that earth was a
necessary sacrifice what about Laurel
Lance her friends her family countless
more like them will perish if we do not
ensure that Oliver Queen is prepared for
what is coming
were you successful yes
I have Doctor Wong
let us proceed. welcome back everyone it's Charlie this is going to be my flash season 6 episode 4 trailer video
and a breakdown
of all the crisis on Infinite Earths scenes
from the flash this week and arrow
so I will be talking about the arrow
episode in this video if you're new to
the channel there is a new flash ring
giveaway all you have to do to enter is
be a subscriber and leave your best
crisis on Infinite Earths theory on the
video we start with  work going
into full-blown villain mode trying to
heal himself first but he finds that he
has to inject other people to do it he
kind of has to consume them so to speak
but really he's converting them into the
goo zombie is just like last week so
he's going after people in the hospital
where he used to work because the whole
idea here is that he's ultimately trying
to heal people in the most twisted
villain way possible but he has to
a bunch of people before he can do that
because he has to heal himself first so
he's doing just as much bad as he is
good and since they're in a hospital and
since it's a Halloween episode because
next week is Halloween week so they're
going full OG Walking Dead all you need
now is Andrew Lincoln guest starring and
popping up in one of the hospital beds
in the middle of the episode with goo
zombies walking all over the place
pretty simple idea it's episode 4 so
really it's kind of like the midpoint of
the flash season with this current
ramsey rosa villain arc so that's why it
seems like he's going crazy so fast
because they have to wrap it up by
episode 8 because episode 9 the
mid-season finale is going to be the
crossover episode in the bee and all
their crisis on Infinite Earths stuff
even though technically there's a lot of
crossover moments happening in the
regular episodes too so whatever's going to happen between him and work it's
going to end by episode 8 which implies
that's going to be their big final
battle moving it all that crisis on
Infinite Earths scenes from the flash
and arrow this week so we met Nash wells
there is possible evidence that he could
be the pariah character from the
crossover you see a version of wells Tom
Cavanagh standing in a very pariah
looking comic book costume so clearly
he's an alternate version of wells in
one of his other scenes during the
episode teased a lot of big multiverse
crisis stuff he talks about travelling
the multiverse propagating ms about
false gods there are no gods which is a
reference to the new gods hypothesis
darkside apocalypse
there's no such thing as mystical mumbo
jumbo or gods with her
our metahumans aliens and false gods
worshipped by simple minded people to
find comfort in myths I just build those
myths we've already seen a mr. miracle
Easter egg on Jay Garrick's map of the
multiverse so it makes sense that they
would be referencing New Gods stuff in
the big Jack Kirby 4th world characters
but we got our nice black Adam Shazam
Easter egg shout out when he started
talking about eternium so we'll find out
what they're doing with that stuff in
the next couple of episodes but moving
into the arrow crisis on Infinite Earths
scenes so the last couple of weeks
Oliver has been collecting stuff dwarf
star alloy and now a scientist to help
the monitor do something with the
materials that Oliver in now Nash wells
seem like they're collecting for him
there's a lot of people that are
wondering if they're going to include an
Easter egg or a version of the cosmic
tuning fork from Infinite Crisis which
is not something that appeared during
the original crisis on Infinite Earths
and originally it was actually created
by an alternate universe Alexander
Luthor who was kind of a villain of
Infinite Crisis the monitor brought the
main version of Lex Luthor back to life
recently at the end of Supergirl last
season but Alexander Luthor was trying
to bring back his universe that had
been destroyed during crisis on Infinite
Earths remember worlds will live worlds
will die they've already erased a number
of Earth's in the multiverse so far
everyone pressed F in the chat for Earth
- hopefully Jessie quick and Harrison
wells of Earth - made it off in time I
don't think they're going to do a version
of Infinite Crisis but they might
incorporate some Easter eggs from that
storyline but Stephen Amell recently
just posted a video last night right
after I posted my flash episode video
saying that he's completely wrapped all
of his scenes on the crossover and
remember the final episode of arrow ever
is going to be one of the final episodes
of the crossover meaning that he is done
guys
crisis on Infinite Earths done I'm done
the crossover
I haven't taken off my Benjamin Button
in the third act makeup yet but I'm done
I would like to say thanks to grant and
all the cool people on the flash when I
say thank you too Caity Lotz and all the
cool people on legends when to say thank
you to Melissa and her whole Supergirl
family I wanted to say thank you to Ruby
and everyone on that woman and I think
that it was mighty cool that
kress came up here and did some stuff
with us so uh yeah Russell we're done I
think that it's probably the coolest
comic book thing that's ever been on TV
he's really selling it they're saying it
is the best comic book thing that has
ever been on TV so there's some hype
raised did the way he talks about it he
almost makes it sound like they're
completely done filming the crossover
but he might just be talking about his
scenes the actual crossover doesn't
start till the second week in December
so most of the time between now and then
is probably them just finishing special
effects and cutting all those promos and
trailers this picture of them all
assembled together might be from the
legends of tomorrow episode and even
though the legends of tomorrow doesn't
come back till January this actually
might be happening during one of the
earlier episodes they'll probably show
up in the crossover before the big
midseason break before they break in
December and then come back in January
for the second half of the crossover
there were a couple new fight scenes
that we got to look at this seems like
it's happening in one of the final
episodes one of the final big battles
because they're fighting the
anti-monitor that's who they're all
running out here in frame but going from
to front this is all their stunt doubles
so that's why it doesn't look exactly
like the actors there's Martian
Manhunter in the back then Dinah's Black
Canary bat woman Supergirl
Sara Lance in white Diggle in a very
Green Lantern looking modification to
his regular suit the flash dreamer from
Supergirl and then wild dog this is just
some of them there are more people in
this scene than these people that you
see right here but it's them doing their
Avengers end game Avengers Assemble
scene all running at the anti-monitor
together at the same time flying across
the frame like I said I think this is
happening in one of the final episodes
and the little boy that everyone's been
asking me about standing next to Stephen
amell's daughter in this group picture
they posted a little while ago but
totally blacked out might wind up being
a younger version of John Kent's
Superboy everyone post her reactions and
your crisis on Infinite Earths
theories in the comments below there's a
whole bunch of other stuff that's
starting really soon too so just a
reminder that Rick and Morty season 4 is
starting in a couple weeks I'll be doing
episode videos for that then Star Wars
the Mandalorian will also be premiering
around the same time I'll also be doing
episode videos for that too
congratulations black wave 54 you're the
giveaway winner from my last big flash
video please email me on the about page
of my channel so I can get your details
everybody click here for my flash season
6 episode 3 video and click here for my
new Star Wars Episode 9 trailer rise
of Skywalker Easter eggs thank you so
much for watching everybody stay awesome I'll see you guys tonight